please welcome Sophia Loren Shirley
MacLaine Halle Berry Nicole Kidman and
Marion Cotillard
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and Hathaway
we loved you as a princess we loved you
in Prada and this year in Rachel Getting
Married
you fearlessly stepped into the shoes of
someone struggling with addiction and
brief I think you're an amazing example
for every young actress in this business
because you're not afraid you're not
afraid to show both your dark and your
bright side this is your first
nomination I have a feeling there will
be many more after this and by the way I
think you have an extraordinary voice so
keep singing to
[Applause]
[Music]
kate winslet with each new role you
continue to push the boundaries of
what's possible your brilliant
performance in the reader encompasses
all the qualities that have always drawn
us to you passion vulnerability and
extraordinary depth as your character
move through time love and the most dire
of circumstances we as your audience
Kate never lose a connection to you this
is yet another unforgettable portrait
from one of our most gifted actresses
and one of our most inspiring
I've been lucky enough to make a small
independent film that then found its way
to global recognition right here on this
stage at the Oscars how wonderful it is
to see it happen again this year from
Melissa Leo
[Applause]
[Music]
you played a woman who's lost everything
yet in the truest American sense still
holds hope for a better day your
authentic portrayal not only brought a
stark focus to those who are too often
left out but it showed you Melissa Leo
as one far too exceptional to be ignored
congratulations
[Applause]
it's hard to know where to begin with
who the next nominee her name itself has
come to represent the whole world of
unmatched excellence so it's probably
best to simply start there Meryl Streep
[Applause]
in doubt you gave us another of your
singular creations a strict Catholic nun
but you let us censor struggle holding
on to her moral beliefs while feeling
the tide of time moving ever against her
for this record you have had 15
nominations
and we've behold the astonishing
astonishing Marin Street
[Applause]
[Music]
a young mother in 1928 loses her only
son and is forced to take part in a
cover-up by the police force
investigating his disappearance
such was the lot for a woman of that
time but this role is played so
authentically is due to the very modern
gifts
Evangelina Jolie search for justice and
for the truth led with heartbreaking
anguish and steadfast determination
reminded us all of the enduring power of
a mother's love as one who would not let
her son be forgotten Angelina Jolie you
were unforgettable
and the Oscar goes to Kate Winslet
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
haha okay that fainting thing Penelope
I'd be lying if them I haven't made a
version of this speech before I think I
was probably eight years old into the
bathroom mirror and this would have been
a shampoo bottle well it's not a shampoo
bottle now
I feel very fortunate to have made it
all the way from there to here and I'd
like to thank some of the people along
the way who had faith in me my friends
are my family especially my mom and dad
who are in this room somewhere dad
whistle or something because then I'll
know where you are
[Applause]
[Music]
and I I also want to thank Hilda cui Li
Dallas Smith and the late much-loved
much miss Robert Garlock and from Peter
Jackson and Emma Thompson to my very own
Sam and Steven Daldry
I'm very lucky to have been given Hanna
Schmitz by Burnage Lincoln and Steven
working with you is an experience I will
never forget
there was no division between the cast
and the crew on this film and that's
what made it so special so to have been
surrounded by remarkable group of people
who provided an unbroken chain of
support from David Cross finds bruno
ganz lena olin from hair and makeup to
cinematography from the art department
to the ADEs and from new york to Berlin
and I'm so lucky to have a wonderful
husband and two beautiful children who
let me do what I love and who love me
just the way that I am Antony and Sidney
this is for you this is for both of you
and I want to acknowledge my fellow
nominees these goddesses I think we all
can't believe we were in a category with
Meryl Streep at all I'm sorry Meryl but
you have to just suck that up
and and and just to the Academy thank
you so much my god
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]